إلد
حصاد 47 سنة
[موسيقى]
قديم
توفار تمير أدار صديقي العزيز مرتاح لفترة طويلة
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته وأشارككم حزنكم
عائلة
عدرا، أنا محتجز في غزة منذ ثلاثة أشهر
عقد من قبل اليشم
[موسيقى]
الإسلامي بيبي نتنياهو أريد أن أتصل بك
وإلى جميع أعضاء مجلس الوزراء الآخرين، لقد تخليتم عني مرة واحدة
ذات يوم في السابع من أكتوبر تركتني بين يديك
من همز إلى لم وأنت تتخلى عني بين الحين والآخر
ثانية واحدة هنا في غزة، ستتركني هنا لمدة ثلاثة
أشهر وكنت بالفعل على وشك الموت أكثر من مرة
أولاً، إنها معجزة أنني مازلت على قيد الحياة، لا تقل ذلك
لعائلتي لقد فعلت كل شيء لرد الجميل
أنا لأنه ليس كذلك
صحيح أريد أن أقول لعائلتي أنني جدا
حقا مثلهم وزارة الدفاع وزارة الدفاع
سقف مود جدا
افتقد جدا جدا افتقد عائلتي وأريد
للعودة إلى المنزل أريد أن أعود وكل شيء
أما بقية المختطفين فسيتم الانتهاء من هذه الحرب اللعينة
أفتقدك كثيرًا، الأمر صعب بالنسبة لي
هنا وكل يوم أعيش فيه هو معجزة
خذني إلى المنزل، توقف عن سرد القصص وتوقف
للتخلي عنا مختطفين جدا سوف نموت هنا
الجميع وفي كل يوم من أيام الحرب يقتل المزيد من الجنود
قتلى، ومزيد من المختطفين، أوقفوا الحرب
وأعدنا بالمختطف إلى المنزل بأمان، من فضلك افعل ذلك
صفقة تبادل لمدة أسبوع مع لحم الخنزير
وأرجعنا
[موسيقى]
البيت
انا اسف لاجلك
[موسيقى]
ل